jour rémy kauffer bonjour merci de
répondre à nos questions êtes historien
spécialiste du renseignement et des
services secrets on vous doit notamment
beaucoup de livres mais le dernier c'est
les grandes affaires des services
secrets paru chez perrin
le négociateurs ukrainiens dit que les
conditions sont suffisantes pour une
rencontre entre zelensky et poutine et
c'est à dire que les négociations
avancent dans le bon sens il faut savoir
du point de vue des ukrainiens on
comprend bien qu'ils ont intérêt à ce
que les négociations avancent parce
qu'ils sont tellement matraqué par la
puissance russe et civils en particulier
on vient d'en parler que il voudrait que
ça aboutisse alors la question est de
savoir est ce que le kremlin est ce que
vladimir poutine a envie que les
négociations aboutissent ou est ce
qu'ils préfèrent attendre un peu
temporisé tout en donnant l'impression
de vouloir négocier d'avoir récupéré une
partie plus substantielle du donbass
parce que vous avez convient d'en parler
également cette région et militairement
disputé mais les ukrainiens en tout cas
avance regagne des villes notamment et
repine ça ça peut faire peser les
négociations de leur côté oui toute
négociation c'est l'expression d'un
rapport de force mais il faudrait savoir
ce qu'on n'arrive pas à déchiffrer
depuis le début qu'elle est la stratégie
exacte du crem là qu'est ce que veut
exactement
vladimir poutine on a l'impression qu'il
en a rabattu un peu par rapport même
beaucoup par rapport à ces objectifs
origines d'origine corps 22
début de l'agression maintenant il faut
savoir ce qu'il se passe dans sa tête
qu'elle est sa stratégie qu est-ce qui
va obtenir maintenant dans cette
configuration si vous voulez est ce
qu'il y a eu un échec des services de
renseignements russes sur cette guerre
qui dure depuis 34 jours aujourd'hui et
vous le disiez les objectifs russes ne
sont pas atteints est ce que les russes
ont surestimé leurs forces et
sous-estimé la résistance ukrainienne on
ne peut pas dire que ce soit une grande
réussite du guerrero quels
renseignements militaires russes c'est à
dire que ils ont visiblement
sous-estimer l'adversaire alors je
dirais que c'est pas nouveau parce qu
autrefois au temps de l'union soviétique
en 1939 staline avait lancé une
offensive sur la finlande avec des
effectifs insuffisants
et puis il a été battu par l'armée
finlandaise et là on a fait venir un
rouleau compresseur qui a obligé les les
finlandais a accepté une paix qui s'est
traduite notamment par la suite par là
ce qu'on appelle la finlandisation et
puis en 56 à budapest mais les russes
pareil vu les soviétiques plus tôt
christophe sorbonne con qu'on écrase
l'insurrection nationale hongroise on
envoie des effectifs insuffisants ils se
font rétamer les russes attendent deux
jours et contre-attaqué la écrase
complètement l'instruction donc oui il
ya un côté reste sous-estimation
qui est assez surprenant quand même
parce que mes bons l'oeuf et exhibe le
mans ils ont pensé que les autres ne
valait pas tripette sk inverse les
renseignements américains là reviennent
en force ce sont eux finalement qui
avait pratiquement la bonne date de
l'intervention russe ils y croyaient et
même boulot dit marie-hélène ce qu'ils
disent et non non non les russes
n'attaqueront pas alors visiblement
l'acier et de l'ensemble de la
communauté américaine du renseignement a
peur doré son blason on se rappelle
qu'il ya eu évidemment les événements
malheureux d'afghanistan l'évacuation
précipitée de l'aghanistan avec le chaos
qui s'en est ensuivie
et on se rappelle aussi de la guerre
contre l'irak avec de trouver à tout
prix des armes de destruction massive
alors que saddam hussein n'avait pas les
armes en question donc ça c était d
échec parce qu'on a passé moi
l'expression dans le cas de l'irak on a
tordu le bras aux services secrets à la
cia y est aussi au mi6 britannique en
leur ordonnant de trouver des mets des
des motifs là ils ont visiblement
redorer leur blason c'est à dire qu'ils
ont correctement prévu que les
soviétiques les russes pardon ne voulait
pas faire ne se livrait pas seulement
une démonstration de force aux
frontières mais qu'ils accèdent à des
milliers d'hommes à la france oui mais
ça reflète une pression là où les
services de renseignements sont bons
c'est pas seulement quand il voit le
dispositif parce que le dispositif avec
les satellites et externaliser qu'il
fasse à l'intervention de communication
c'est de savoir quelle est l'intention
là ils ont correctement dit que
l'intention était attaquée alors rémy
kauffer j'aimerais qu'on s'arrête sur le
cas d'un homme romane abramovitch qui
est un oligarque russe et qui participe
visiblement puisque moscou l'a confirmé
à à ces négociations avec les ukrainiens
d'abord est-ce que ça vous étonne qu un
oligarque russe participe à des
pourparlers avec les ukrainiens ça
dépend de ce que veut le kremlin ça
n'est pas vrai ce que ça veut dire
également de ce que veut abramovitch
parfois c'est pas un partenaire égal
avec le kremlin dans le plateau d'une
balance évidemment c'est le kremlin qui
pèse alors si si poutine et le kremlin a
estimé que c'était intéressant pour deux
mais de le mettre pourquoi pas c'est pas
assaini surprenant n'est pas surprenant
mais est ce que il y arrive souvent que
des oligarques participent à des
négociations pense plutôt à des
politiques normalement c'est des gens
qui sont des représentants de l'état ne
participent pas des négociations
internationales mais là on est dans une
situation très particulière alors
abramovitch à se donner l'impression
d'être un peu indépendant un peu plus
indépendant il ya des intérêts surtout
en angleterre chelsea
bon la question c'est comme apparemment
lisse et trouvait pas très bien et deux
négociateurs ukrainiens se sont trouvés
pas très bien à la question est de
savoir qu'est ce qui leur est arrivé
alors l'empoisonnement donc damart
d'abramovitch et de deux négociateurs
ukrainiens on parle de symptômes plutôt
léger un
des rougeurs des rites ation des yeux
problèmes de peau visage et aux mains
l'a visiblement ce n'est pas une
question d supprimés est d'atteindre à
leur vie c'est quoi c'est un message
pour leur faire peur alors s'il est
confirmé qu'il s'agit de quelque chose
qui aurait été décidé par les russes
c'est l'argentin allait attendu mais
quand vous faites ça le confirmer jamais
de manière directe vous le confirmer de
manière indirecte
la décision s'il s'agit bien d'une
tentative d'empoisonnement semi
empoisonnement la décision n'aurait pu
être prise que au plus haut sommet de
l'état au kremlin
alors dans ce cas ci on est dans cette
hypothèse
pourquoi pourquoi peut-être dans cette
configuration peut-être pour gagner un
peu de temps et créé un malaise au
niveau des négociations trouver
peut-être un moyen de peut-être agiter
le chiffon rouge
si j'ose dire sous le nez des ukrainiens
se dire bon c'est vrai parce que à
partir du moment le le kremlin a accepté
des négociations
le problème c'est que soient les
négociations aboutissent vite sous elle
traîne en longueur ce qui peut être
c'était aussi une vieille technique
soviétique de de rendre la situation à
des chiffres ap parce que ça traînait en
longueur les occidentaux réagissent sur
un tempo plus rapide mais ça dit quoi
finalement en coulisse pourquoi est ce
que les russes s'en prendraient à
abramovitch parce qu'ils auraient une
position modérée qu'il y aurait en
coulisses d une ligne dure qui ne le
suivrait pas alors comment vous
empoisonner les gens si j'ose dire je
vais pas donner de mauvais côtés les
sectateurs mai soit vous empoisonner
leur nourriture
soit vous leur vouent les asperger de
gaz et de produits de ce genre alors les
gaz et produisent ce genre ça près
difficile quand même talent dans leur
salle de réunion de ce type la
nourriture empoisonnée pourquoi pas et
la nourriture empoisonnée
parfois c'est mal distribué parce que
l'assiette parce quelqu'un d'autre et
c'est peut-être que abramovitch wii est
victime peut être victime tout
simplement c'est sur place d'un
collatéral bas sur place s'est pas fait
c'est pas facile alors cessé c'est une
vieille technique chinoise
d'empoisonnement puisque ce avec la
nourriture chinoise elle vous est servi
dans votre assiette individuel donc ça a
été une technique il est certes un repas
où la plupart des convives sortait en
très bonne forme et puis un des convives
arrivé chez lui tombé malade et mourir
là il ya peut-être une erreur mais que
les ukrainiens soit derrière cet
empoisonnement présumé ça vous paraît
pas du tout crédible ça me paraît
difficile je ne vois pas ce qu'ils
chercheraient ils ont plutôt intérêt
compte tenu du jeu le disait du
matraquage de leur population ils ont
plutôt intérêt à ce que les hostilités
se soit au moins suspendu c'est ce
qu'ils demandent donc vouloir ralentir
les négociations me paraît pas dans leur
intérêt merci pour vos explications rémi
kauffer ge